[Music]
right we've been dating for over a year
now and I think it's about time people
met my beautiful girlfriend what about
us taking an adventure ease like Queens
Singapore Colleen's wedding do you want
to be my family every time I bring them
up Jesus maybe his parents are poor and
he has to send them money let's take a
bag then get you checked into Frisco
with this so your family is rich we're
comfortable that is exactly what a super
rich person would say 1.2 minutes the
Nick you're dating is Nick young yeah
you guys know them ourselves yeah
there's just the biggest developers and
all the Singapore Beijing bachelors if
you aren't just rich they're crazy rich
you really should have told me that
you're like the principal um of Asia
that's ridiculous
much more of a hurry mum this is Rachel
chick she just thinks you're some like
unrefined banana there's a few fingers
no on the outside or white on the inside
I chose to raise a family for me it was
a privilege but for you you may think
it's old-fashioned don't you want it to
be happy I know you're not what Nick
needs she's like trying to play games
chicken with me do you think I'm gonna
swerve like a chicken but UK for you
gonna roll up and be like bok-bok [ __ ]
okay maybe like not as aggressive
I met a girl I fell in love and I want
to marry her your Nicholas young you're
untouchable but Rachel's not if you
prepped Rachel to face the wolves I
really admire you
it takes guts coming all the way over
here facing expanding I know this much
you will never be enough no it's about
time someone stood up to answer Eleanor
for you not me Oh God
Chicago is over here
[Music]
[Applause]
ever since I can remember my family has
been my whole life Rachel Rachel if Nick
chose me he would lose his family and if
he chose his family he might spend the
rest of his life resent him you you dad
you got an ass you got nastier
[Music]